bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on au move à
une bourde congress à barcelone et j'ai
pu prendre en main le nouveau samsung
galaxy s l'ofppt et s9 plus les nouveaux
smartphones haut de gamme de san jose
[Musique]
ils ont vraiment désherbe déjà vu et
pourtant il apporte de vraies
innovations et permettent de conforter
samsung dans leur place de leader des
photophones la grande évolution au
niveau de l'appareil photo se fait au
niveau de la double ouverture vous avez
vous d'autres bases en f 2.4 et une
ouverture à passe luminosité en f1
points 5
alors qu'est ce que ça veut dire en
réalité ça veut tout simplement dire que
lorsque vous êtes en conditions de bonne
luminosité votre appareil va capter
vraiment les moindres détails et vous
faire vraiment des photos il perd
optimisé par contre lorsque vous êtes en
faible luminosité
il va switcher automatiquement en tout
cas dans le mode automatique en f1
points 5
ce qui est hyper intéressant si vous
voulez c'est que vous allez avoir des
photos en faible luminosité qui vont
être encore meilleur en camp de
meilleure qualité
on savait déjà que samsung était super
monde pour les photos et pour la vidéo
sur les smartphones mais là ils vont
encore plus loin
sorte une technologie conde retrouvées
sur aucun smartphone auparavant donc il
montre plusieurs choses
ils n'ont déjà qu'ils ont un appareil
qui est au top ils m'ont vraiment leur
capacité à innover sera marché qui est
de plus en plus concurrentiel mais
répond très clairement apple et sortir
l'iphone glisser dans l'ariège qui est
vraiment très très bon et qui excellent
pour la photo et la vidéo et il se
positionne également leader par rapport
à warwick pousse vraiment derrière pour
gagner des parts de marché sur le snuff
vous avez une caméra arrière de 12
mégapixels sur le s9 plus vous avez une
double caméra arrière de 12 mégapixels
une caméra je dirais un peu plus
standard et une caméra téléobjectif pour
pouvoir notamment vous aider lorsque
vous allez faire le mode portrait à
l'avant une caméra de cette fille 8
mégapixels comme je le disais que vous
avez le mode automatique ou là
effectivement le changement d'ouverture
va se gérer complètement automatiquement
ça va être vraiment transport entre vous
et vous avez un mode pro vous pouvez
choisir votre ouverture pouvait régler
les iso on va aller beaucoup plus loin
l'idée c'est vraiment si vous laissez
pour les amateurs de photo d'abord un
photophone très complet sur lequel on
peut vraiment paramétrer et où on peut
aller plus loin au niveau de ses
réglages
autre innovation qui est vraiment très
très intéressante sur ce s 9 sur 6,9 s
de plus c'est le super slow motion
le super slow
quelque chose pour trouver sur le sony
xperia x1 et là effectivement on vient
de voir arriver directement sur ces
samsung galaxy s 9,9 plus alors qu'est
ce que ça va vous apporter
si vous voulez on est tout de suite pas
vraiment dans du super slow motion à
qualité professionnelle parce qu'on
filme en 720p c'est à dire en acheter et
ne parlons pas de full hd alors
carrément pas de 4k par contre ça vous
permet effectivement d'avoir un effet
qui est très sympa et pouvoir l'utiliser
notamment pour le partage sur les
réseaux sur les médias sociaux
c'est ça qui est vraiment intéressant si
vous voulez et on voit vraiment la
direction stratégique de samsung c'est
d'aller encore plus loin sur les
créateurs pas forcément sur la création
haute définition avec une super qualité
mais sûr de la création et du partage
rapide sur les réseaux sociaux
on va très clairement que c'est le choix
stratégique qui est fait par samsung
aujourd'hui alors ce super seul mot
chaîne peut le faire en 960 images par
seconde
c'est à dire que pendant ce héros 1,2
seconde vous allez sortir une vidéo qui
fait 6 secondes
une vidéo sans audio samsung vous permet
de caler une musique derrière et pouvoir
exporter de partager très rapidement
autre nouveauté très intéressant c'est
les ar emoji là on voit qu'on va très
clairement en concurrence aux animaux ji
d'apple lorsque apple vous propose des
petits animaux jean ce sont des mjs soit
une licorne que ce sont un cas car que
ce soit autre chose qui vont être
animées avec les ailleurs emoji vous
allez pouvoir scanner votre visage allez
pouvoir avoir un emoji de vous en
réalité augmentée alors c'est pas un
érudit parfait ça retrouve vous rentrez
mais c'est assez ressemblants après vous
pouvez customiser vous pouvez changer
ces photos lui mettent des lunettes les
billets différemment
vous avez aussi la possibilité d'avoir
des émaux dire un peu plus classique que
vous allez animer et c'est vrai que
c'est réactif alors par contre je trouve
que ça marche bien c'est réactif c'est
pas aussi réactif que vous retrouvez sur
l'iphone bis et les animaux ji ça marche
bien mais on voit que le délai de
réponse est un petit peu inférieur de
l'hôpital c'est normal parce que vous
avez pas les caméras trou d'aix que
propose apple avec un scan à en 3d de
votre visage très techno samsung utilise
uniquement la reconnaissance de votre
visage pas de reconnaissance 3d bon le
mapping ce cas plutôt bien ça marche
bien c'est correct
d'ailleurs c'est aussi un des points qui
est mis en avant par samsung qui est
plutôt intéressant c'est la
reconnaissance de visage
on est dérouillée rapidement en réalité
on recycle un petit peu l'ancien si vous
voulez ce conte par rapport à ce qu'on a
sur le s suite c'est à dire une caméra
avant qui va on reconnaître votre visage
n'est pas du tout les reliefs qui va
pouvoir être couplé un scanner d'iris ce
à dire que vous allez déverrouiller soit
avec la connaissance faciale de votre
caméra soit avec le scanner d'iris c'est
votre smartphone qui fera le choix
directement c'est pas aussi puissants
que ceux qu'on retrouve avec apple et
facebook
mais ça marche plutôt pas mal après la
question c'est la sécurisation est ce qu
on est hyper sécurisé à mon avis on est
quand même un peu moins sécurisés que
par rapport à ce qu'on peut retrouver
chez chez apple à contrôler vérifiés
ultérieurement entre poids qui est super
intéressante les airs et mozilla ou
apple vous permet pas du tout de les
partager les ondes et sur les médias
sociaux vous pouvez uniquement les
envoyer via l'application de message
d'apple là avec les arn bogies de
samsung vous pouvez les partager sur les
réseaux sociaux
et ça c'est vraiment bien cela chat
facebook
sur plainte réseaux sociaux que envoyés
par des sages encore là mais pas mal de
possibilités et ça c'est vrai que c'est
bien parce que apple un petit peu trop
de roulis donc on est un petit peu
frustré là avec ce système de samsung c
permet une vache mais plus intéressant
côté vidéo vous pouvez bien évidemment
toujours filmé en 4k alors maintenant on
va parler du design c'est vrai que je
trouve que le le design très clairement
s'inspire du galaxy et suites et un
style plus alors c'est normal parce que
si vous voulez ça ne sonne ne pas vous
sortir un produit complètement
différente tous les ans d'une parce que
sa demande par mail offre beaucoup de
recherche ça demande un certain temps
l'idée de cs 9 est 9 plus c'est d'avoir
un produit intermédiaire entre la suite
l'es10 qui va arriver l'année prochaine
par contre le goût mais quand même bien
fait vous avez des bords qui sont
légèrement plus arrondi par rapport aux
et suite c'est vrai que l'ago table
sousse un peu plus léger un peu plus
light
d'un point de vue esthétique c'est quand
même plutôt pas mal foutu autre point
qui changent effectivement c'est au
niveau de l'arrière goût trop le capteur
digital qui va se positionner juste en
dessous de l'appareil photo du capteur
photo moi je continue à penser que la
position n'est pas idéal d'aidé faudrait
un peu plus bas effectivement on trouve
assez facilement mais vous êtes toujours
le bout de votre index va aller flirter
avec la caméra et ça pour moi en tout
cas c'est un vrai point de regrets le
bouton bixby est toujours présent sur
l'appareil d'ailleurs samsung nous
annoncer que bixby serait enfin en
français d'ici la fin 2010 8 là pour le
coup c'est vrai que c'est bien mais d'un
autre côté ça me saoule mais énormément
de temps pour adapter les clients
français et ça c'est vraiment dommage
alors les écrans on ne change pas vous
avez des écrans super amoled l'écran
infiniti
qualité qui toujours temps à vérifier
maintenant par rapport à l'écran de
l'iphone 10 lequel est le meilleur parce
que l'iphone disent aussi un super écran
oled en écran 5,8 pouces sur l'ès 9 et
6,2 pouces sur le s9 plus autre super
nouveauté c'est le son vous avez des
hauts parleurs stéréo à kg un son dolby
atmos alors c'est vrai que là on est sur
un salon il ya énormément de bruit c'est
très compliqué de se rencontrent mais
malgré tout le sont poussés à fond on
arrive très clairement a bien capté
leçon à se rendre compte un peu de la
spatialisation du dolby à bosse et c'est
vrai que c'est hyper intéressant
[Musique]
alors imaginez chez vous dans un lieu où
il n'y a pas forcément un énorme bruit
de fond vous allez vraiment pouvoir
profiter d'un son très immersif une
excellente qualité audio aka j'ai
vraiment connu pour avoir un
savoir-faire une qualité au lieu qu'il
faut vraiment top
et ça c'est vraiment si un point
extrêmement positif sans cesse la phase
la plus cotée performances en france en
tout cas on va retrouver un exynos 9810
pour les snuff 4 gigas de ram et pour le
s9 +6 giga de ram
côté batterie ya rien de bien nouveau on
a une 3008 est antérieure paulès 9000
3500 milliards terreur pour le s9 plus
j'imagine que tout ce qui va être
processeur gpu tout ça va être vraiment
optimisé gagner vraiment en autonomie
mais c'est pas du côté de la batterie en
tout cas que la différence va se faire
on garde toujours le port jack une
certification ip68 résistant aux
éclaboussures à l'eau à la poussière
alors allez pas vous baigner avec as pas
fait pour mais en tout cas si vous
prenez la pluie il sera protégé
normalement tout devrait plutôt bien se
passer
un bluetooth 5.0 et tourne sous oreo 8.0
vous êtes en plus cette fois ci une
double carte sim
ça s'est vraiment bien ce qui fait que
vous avez dit en usage professionnel ou
pour insérer votre sim pro et votre sim
perso si vous partez à l'étranger si
vous voyagez vous pourrez insérer la
carte sim du pays
ça c'est vraiment un point positif
toujours de la recharge par induction et
l'application smart sim apps samsung met
un point d'honneur à connecter tous les
objets de votre quotidien c'est
l'équivalent se retrouve chez google
avec google os est-ce qu'on peut
retrouver aussi chez apple mais ça me
semble là où ils vont encore plus loin
s'il voulait c'est que au niveau
l'électroménager sont extrêmement
présents dont vous allez pouvoir
connecter votre four votre réfrigérateur
votre plaque de cuisson
vos ampoules philip sion on peut
imaginer on peut imaginer des histoires
commandes et on peut imaginer une
surveillance au niveau de la
sécurisation de votre intérieur tout
connecté tout centralisé avec
l'application de samsung et ça c'est
super intéressant s'il voulait parce que
on voit qu'on va encore plus loin par
rapport à ses applications pour la
maison connectée mais ça restait qualité
parce qu'on va parler dans une prochaine
vidéo
autre nouveauté ces implantations du
deck spad on avait le texte sorti
l'année dernière et qui est plutôt pas
mal non on reste un peu sur notre faim
parce qu'il fallait forcément une souris
et un clavier là avec le deck spad plus
besoin de souris de claviers en tout cas
pour utilisation un peu classique vous
posez votre smartphone vous le branchez
et vous pouvez l'utiliser comme un petit
trackpad utilise aussi le clavier pour
écrire directement sur votre écran c'est
plutôt pas mal
on voit qu'on va encore plus loin dans
la centralisation des infos au niveau de
votre smartphone à smartphone devient le
coeur de votre vie numérique ou encore
plus le coeur de votre ordinateur sans
la vue il n'y a pas de projet qui
foisonne de ce côté là d'un projet linh
dan rather qu'ils nous croient vraiment
dans ce sens que j'ai pu voir d'ailleurs
au csa la délégation pas très beau temps
enfin c'est très intéressant parce qu'on
voit que le smartphone est toujours plus
au coeur de votre vie numérique
l'espèce est le plus seront dispo à
partir du 15 mars de cette année est en
précommande et maintenant d'ailleurs si
tu t'intéresses décennies des liens dans
la description côté arrive on trouve le
s9 à 859 euros et le s9 plus à 959 euros
à l'organisme offre de reprise vous
invite à aller voir tout ça vous avez le
lien dans la description en france est
disponible en trois couleurs en ultra
violet en noir carbone et en bleu corail
j'ai toujours une préférence pour le
noir carbone sobriété simplicité
efficacité je trouve que c'est super
élégant mais les autres couleurs sont
plutôt pas mal aussi
il faut le reconnaître qu'est ce que
samsung nous montre avec cette
démonstration de force sait déjà qu'ils
ont le meilleur photophone il était déjà
extrêmement bien placé avec les suicides
plus là ils vont encore plus loin
ils sont à mon avis en 2018 leader sur
le marché du faux tofu démontre
également que pour l'instant avec cs 9,9
plus ils ont le meilleur smartphone sur
android
la cible comme je le disais ce sont les
créateurs contenu créateur contenus sont
pas forcément des personnes qui en font
un usage professionnel mais toutes les
personnes qui utilisent leur smartphone
pour faire des photos des vidéos qui
veulent aller plus loin et qu'il est
partage sur les réseaux sociaux
est-ce que c'est des produits qu'il faut
acheter dès aujourd'hui alors très
clairement si vous avez besoin de
changer votre portable si vous avez un
portable qui est un petit peu anciens
anciens anglicans guillemets rien on va
parler à partir du s cette es6 si vous
avez un portable d'un autre constructeur
vous voulez aller chez samsung
je vous êtes vous invite vraiment
alléchant cs 9,9 plus parce que très
clairement ce sont d'excellents
smartphone si maintenant vous avez des
suites et suit plus
si vous avez un tweet qui ne voient pas
particulièrement l'intérêt de soutien
sur ce produit parce que c'est quand
même un certain investissement un
certain budget il ya effectivement des
nouveautés il ya des améliorations
elles sont très intéressantes si vous
voulez vraiment les plus rentables de
photographies mais après si vous voulez
l'utiliser pour la photo je dirais
normale avec une excellente qualité
si vous pouvez très bien aller sur le
site et suis plus qu'ils vont vraiment
parfaitement bien la faire si vous avez
ensuite et ensuite plus vous pouvez
attendre l'année prochaine parce que les
vraies innovations vont sortir sur les
10 c est 10 plus en 2019 en gros pour
résumer on est sur un smartphone haut de
gamme de beat generation et on attend la
génération prochaine pour voir vraiment
un petit peu la grande claque à ce qui
va arriver d'autant plus qu'on attend
les smartphones avec des écrans pliables
pourquoi pas un galaxy x il ya plein de
choses qui vont arriver
donc je pense que ça ne sonne va
continuer à innover va continuer à être
leader dans le domaine du photoforum
domaine de la téléphonie mobile
il faut garder une certaine mesure parce
qu'on voit que apple avait vraiment pris
des risques avec son iphone glisse en
2017 alors aussi que samsung avait
innové avec les suites et elle suit plus
la liesse 9,9 plus sont une vraie
innovation par rapport aux suicides plus
du côté du point de vue en tout cas de
la caméra avec l'appareil photo
le design est bien l'écran et bien c'est
un bon produit mais je demande encore à
voir ce qui va arriver cette année parce
qu'à mon avis il va y avoir plein de
nouveautés et plein de produits qui vont
être super bague il pas vous ce que vous
en pensez comment vous les trouvez csf
est de plus est ce que vous pensez qu'il
vaille le coup est ce que vous pourriez
vous laisser tenter
marquis moto sans commentaire est
collectée est solide bien évidemment à
vous abonner parce qu'on va parler
toujours plus de téléphonie mobile de
produits high tech de vie numérique
il ya plein plein plein plein de choses
j'ai vu plein de choses complètement
dingue au mwc j'en suis qu'au début
et alors plein d'autres trucs à boire
donc rester connecté abonnez vous merci
à vous d'avoir regardé la vidéo j'avais
bien évidemment comme d'hab abcd jolie
pousse à partager la vidéo avec tous vos
amis
et puis n'oubliez pas que vous êtes les
meilleurs mark et moi tous vos
commentaires à très bientôt le jour
brasse ciao
[Musique]